がたん、、、どん
ドゥッテンダン、ドゥッダン♪
テレッテテレ〜、カタ（ぶつかる音）
シャーシャー、シャー（ヨーヨーの音）
チュ♡（愛してるよマイハニー）
デレッデッデレ♪
デュッデュッデレーデーレデッ
痛っ♡あっ♡あっ♡
デッデッデレーデーレデッ
パッパッパッパッパー
パー
意味無きくるくる　そして
ドゥキューン（ハートを撃ち抜く音）
てーてってってて〜
パァァァン（ハート撃ち抜く音）
クルクルクル
, -.―――--.､
,ｲ,,i､ﾘ,,リ,,ﾉﾉ,,;;;;;;;;ヽ
.i;}'　　　　　　　"ﾐ;;;;:}
|} ,,..､_､　 , _,,,..､ 　|;;;:|
|} ,_tｭ,〈 　ﾋ''tｭ_　 i;;;;|
|　 ｰ'　|　｀ - 　 　 ﾄ'{
.｢| ｲ_i _ >､ }〉}
｀{|　_.ﾉ;;/;;/,ゞ;ヽ､ 　.!-'
|　　 　＝'" 　 　 |
iﾞ ､_　　ﾞ,,,　 ,,　' {
丿＼　￣￣　 _,,-"ヽ
''"~ヽ　　＼､_;;,..-" ＿　,i`ー-
ヽ､oヽ/ ＼　 /o/　 |
ドヤ!
皆さんどうでしたか?ｳﾌﾝ♥
私のヨーヨーさばき（自分の下手さを隠してる）
コンッ（落とす音やっぱり下手）
まあそんなに僕めちゃくちゃ上手いわけじゃないんですけど（知ってた）
今日は
普通のヨーヨの長さあるじゃないですかひもの
で大体ちょうどこの画面のこのくらいの長さで
１メートルぐらいだと思いますひもの長さが
・・・・・・・・。（えっと何話そう）
短い！（ヤケクソ）
というわけで今回は
このヨーヨーあるんですけども
このヨーヨー
改造してひもの長さをもっと長くします
ヨーヨーってひもの長さが長ければ長いほど
ダァァァァイナミィィィィックな技が出来るんすよ
多分そうです
多分できると思います
多分できると思うけど
今日は
ヨーヨーの長さをめちゃくちゃ長くして
ヨーヨーをPLAY♥して
私が真のねヨーヨースペシャリストになると
（まあ、あくまでもヒカキンさんよりは上くらいだけど）
脱初心者を目指して頑張っていこうと思います
では逝こう♥！！
この橋の上からヨーヨーをひゅっとやって
トゥルルルルってやります
とりあえずこの１メートルのひもをもっと伸ばします
はいというわけでひもつけていきます
ギリギリ水面に届くか届かないかぐらいでスリップさせていきたいです
見とけよ
世界のヨーヨー界に衝撃を与えてやるからな　　　　　（ヒカキン除く）
っしゃｷﾀｷﾀ
おっけおっけ✕2
完璧でしょこれ
これでヨーヨー完成させます
よぉーし
くいくい、くいく、ぷち
あっ
（グキィッ）
はいというわけでこれで
糸の長さを１３０メトル・・・
（グへっ）
糸の長さを１３０メートル以内なら
どれだけでも自由に操れます
じゃ巻いていきます
ここでニュースをお伝えします
午前五時30分に誘拐がありました
警察は犯人をまだ追っている模様
.................（話すことがない）
完全におかしいでしょこれはww
ヨーヨーよりひもの方が太くなってるww
一回どれくらいの長さなのか計ってみます
落としたらわかりやすくない❓
これの２倍ぐらいの長さだと思うんだよね
大体
（ヒュッ）
コロコロコロコロコロコロ
ドボン
全然✕3
あるんだけどwwww
今のでわかったのは思ったより
そんなにいらないっす
多分
うぺちょんぬうペチョンぬグヘヘ
これで橋からやります
じっちゃん；え？
橋からヨーヨーをこう・・・
じっちゃん；ヨーヨーをどうすんの？
ヨーヨーをこうやって
橋から
ヒューーッ
じっちゃん；それで？
わっすげ（じっちゃんが）
やってみようと思います
ヒュンっ
ヨーヨー・・・
俺はお前を信じる・・・・・
はいというわけでみなさん準備が完了しました
多分１０メートル
ぐらい高さはあると思います
ここからこのヨーヨーを
落として
僕の最高の本気の力で
ヨーヨーをするんで
なんとかスリープして
ここまで戻ってきたらいいなと思っております
では行きます
行きますっっっ
行きますっ（キリッ）
ボチャンっ
それは・・・
趣深い音だった・・・・
すいません長かったみたいです
とりあえずハサミで切って水面ギリギリのところで戻ってくるぐらいの長さにしてみようと思います
というわけでだいぶ短くしました
多分８メートルぐらいにはなったと思います
これでもう一回やってみましょう
ヒューン
ボチャン
あー惜しいっ
惜しい！惜しい！
すげー回転するんだけど
何何何何
まだちょっと多分長かった
もうちょっと切ります
はいというわけで多分７メートルぐらいにはなりました
次こそは行きます
♂ﾁｰﾝ
うお！？
ナイスヒット
（♪はじめの心の中song♪）